you dirty can you do my leg
yes thank you appreciate it
[Music]
but you gotta like Ashley you know hey
bro let me rub them yeah yeah yeah like
a Subway sandwich right now ankles
around their ankles
[Music]
okay what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and welcome to
the hot ones summer special
it's the summer special with hot
questions and even hotter wings and to
celebrate the season and style we
welcome back Joe G and rich Bryan yes
sir they have a new hit single out now
called midsummer madness later this
month they'll release head in the clouds
the first-ever posse album from 88
rising and on September 22nd you can
catch them at 88 risings head in the
clouds music and arts festival here in
los angeles tickets are on sale now
jouji rich Brian welcome back to the
show thank you for having us you're the
first duo to ever return to the hot one
seat how does it feel to be back I'm
excited because I'm shining I've been
trying to gain weight a little bit you
know so this is good for me a lot of
protein yeah and definitely it's a
challenge that like you know we want to
get further than we did last time
exactly which is impossible to do
because you guys both made it through
but Brian after your hot ones appearance
you've publicly apologized for talking
with your mouth full are you gonna
switch anything up this time around nope
I'm still gonna talk my [__] mouth
full like you're nuts Hank and then Joe
G let me read off to you the top five
most popular hot ones of all time and
we're talking about a catalogue with
over a hundred twenty episodes okay
Kevin Hart number one post Malone key
and Peele Terry Crews and then Joe G
doing laps around Natalie Portman
Charlize Theron Michael B Jordan do you
ever wake up in the morning overwhelmed
by your own clout well I'm oh if I'm if
I'm up there with Terry Crews then yeah
bug all right you guys ready to give it
another round yes yes
[Music]
here we go mm-hmm
odd huevos rancheros this morning's is
not gonna end well so later this month
you're dropping head in the clouds a
project that you did with your other
labelmates at 88 rising is it true that
oh three Greedo when he was on swimming
pools he worked his way onto that track
by crashing your guys studio session I
like to put on Animal Planet just
without without sound or anything either
it's either Animal Planet like American
Dad for the vibe for the vibe yeah but
Animal Planet was on and he he came in
and he was just like mesmerised like
he's never like seen these animals
before and she's whoa Wow Wow
he appreciates it like I've noted that
yeah and he was like looking at the
birds like yo they're flying unison like
it would be like in the middle of them
freestyling isn't it but yeah apparently
that night he damn taken off the [__]
jacket on wing one yeah it's so like he
that night he already made like five six
songs already within the span of like
four hours there's no fast so fast crazy
what's the story behind black boy going
so hard on let it go that he ended up
vomiting up sprite he just he just goes
really hard and he's such a such a great
dancer such a fun guy that sometimes you
just lose your sprite yeah you do
everyone knows that yeah it happened oh
you took your sunglasses off huh I lost
it you guys can keep them on them and
I'm doing I'm gonna wait till it fully
clouds up and then when people see this
my soul jouji I'm feeling you're just
gonna be naked by the end of this at
this rate mm-hmm without the wings I
would still do it
growing up in Chicago summers to me
meant old style tall boys at Wrigley
Field and giving architectural tours
from the Chicago River one boat ride at
a time but I'm curious when you think of
this summers in Indonesia the summers in
Japan what are the things that stand out
summer in Indonesia so I can summer
every day it's totally so hot I just
think of traffic and seeing kids smoke
cigarettes that's all I think about
when midsummer madness dropped you
tweeted midsummer madness out now kiss
somebody for me on the lips
yeah you guys remember your first summer
romance I think mine was like a forced
kiss like on me it was great was like a
train station just like and then and
then yeah I was a man what's the
greatest summer blockbuster and your
guy's opinion I had this phase of my
life roses watching a lot of American
Pie says in America now just like Danny
I want to live that life you know I want
to be Jason Biggs I learned about
shotgunning beers and then when I was in
my house at the time we just had like a
lot of canned drinks it was an alcohol
it wasn't even soda it says like this
like sweet drink thing and then I like I
was like do it in my bathroom I was just
like shotgun like can drinks I'm gonna
feel cool oh my want to take off my size
for this there you go I might've just
touched my eyes first I can be bad that
was the mistake I made last time
actually and you didn't learn from it I
didn't really okay did it I did it again
yeah yeah
Oh Dom to the rescue oh thank you
[Music]
it's really good it's really [__]
good man it actually is
I haven't had wings is getting them up
in a bit not a lot of wings so Brian
when you were on this very show you said
cooking for people is such a pure thing
to do it's like saying I love you
without saying it it's a dream of ours
here at first we feast to make a food
show for each of you guys and without
giving away too many keys what's the
food show that you'd like to see each
other make for me I would love to just
go around New York check out trash cans
and just review food that's been thrown
out that's pretty good and and just like
the whole point of the show is to guess
what it was you know because it's
probably like it's been there for a long
time and this was just like [__] up
this was a pulled pork sandwich yeah
pesto Penant I like the idea of I always
hear sure about like a coffee that's
been passed through a cat there's like
urine wine like you're English people
using urine for [__] I know like Kashmir
cat was telling me that in in Norway
there's a fish you marinate it in soap I
want to try that but just stuff that you
know unorthodox ingredients be cool yeah
you right well Sean burger I hope that
you were paying attention to the pitches
they sound compelling they sound like
hits to me are you guys ready to move on
let's do it
oh [__] a little bit hot so it wouldn't
be a summer special unless we talked
about beach bods and Brian I know that
you've been hitting the gym hard lately
what are your tips for staying fit for
bikini season my chips would be don't to
go to the gym go at the front you know
cuz me personally I cannot go to the gym
by myself
gosh it's weird and trying to gain
weight drink a mass gainer you know two
servings a day two heaping scoops and
that [__] really helps I gained 17
pounds within two months and then Jodie
I know that you tweeted about gaining
and losing a lot of weight for the yeah
right video yeah yeah and then you said
that you wanted to look nasty in the
cover art and in certain scenes
can you explain what your vision was
when I made that song I felt really ugly
that was I think that's like the what
was behind the song so it's like I knew
that I had the shoot for the for the art
like in about a month I was like all
right I'm just gonna treat myself like
[__] just like eat whatever just do
whatever grew my hair out to so just
like let's just make me look the worst
and then so it came down to that and
then after that like I just like cut my
hair and then stop eating badly I just I
would like run of it and and then in two
weeks like I was back to normal so well
I have to say you are looking good from
last I saw you when we were running
through that Japanese convenience store
my me
[Music]
all right so this next one is the lowest
calientes we're calling it the sauce of
summer it's a summery sauce this is very
summery holy [__] how did you yeah you
got some scientists on your team we put
summer in a bottle for you guys Ilan
must watch the [__] out well as you guys
know already we have a recurring segment
on a show called explaining that
Granberry do a deep dive on our guys on
Instagram put interesting pictures that
need more context is fun we have some
Brian pictures we have some Joe G
pictures the comments section is open so
if you maybe want to fill in the blanks
on one of Brian's IG pics go ahead if
you want to fill in the blanks I'm one
of Joe G's picks go ahead all right
laptop please not one sip of the
chocolate milk yet I'm kind of proud of
myself yeah you've been doing pretty
well all right first things first
Joe G on Patrol given the context of
like who was originally on that
motorcycle man lieutenant luster
lieutenant monster so this was an
Indonesia it was like right in front of
my house and then um we had a police
escort
and then um they do that was on that is
like the scariest person ever this dude
like I think I think I heard about him
like pistol whipping somebody so he's a
legend like yeah he just he just goes
around and does that yeah what did you
see I we might have not been in the same
car but um he a car was trying to merge
yeah and he he skirts like right in
front of that car like in front of our
car - and like kicks it and then like
bangs the the hood with his gun and go
he's crazy like yells no
you saw that yeah you can ask Anders
he's he's all that surprised it was
amazing
but then he was chill and cool enough
though I'll let you hop on it for an IG
pick yeah yeah yeah that's that's that's
and you and you [__] wore his helmet -
that's true that's the helmet that his
head has been like down I'm honored
that's a lotta L are a lot of pistol
wishing
[Music]
okay it always jumps from like again
yeah I remember this because it's it was
it was fine up until up until you get to
the six or the seventh yeah this is good
this is fun we're gonna cry hmm
so over the past six months you and your
label mates have traveled the globe
doing an eight city tour in Asia and of
course the Double Happiness tour here in
the US when you think about all of the
surprise guests that you've brought out
be it ski mask the slump gun or Chief
Keef who got the crowd most hyped
honestly people get the most hype for
like they get the hype for like ichima
when like we bring everybody on oh and
like skis there everyone they're like
yeah just like Oh everyone's giving a
mic and everyone just kind of like
screaming at lives to the point you
can't even hear the song yeah it's just
what's one way that plane is showing
Asia is different than when you play a
tourist stop in North America I feel
like they do this first of all it was
somewhat someone was doing this at this
price stage it's like a heart apparently
but I thought I was like an offensive
gesture so I was about like it's on
space but then last minute like they're
like no no it's it's it's a good thing
it's a good thing after the third time
you punch them in the face exactly like
he was already out
all right so this next one is the bun
stir
speaking of international it's out of
Australia I was just in Australia this
so nice
I paid a kangaroo's and lake sheeps and
[__] yeah have you seen that video of
the kangaroo game punched in the face
yes that's my favorite and then to the
video of the kangaroo like coming to
this dude's house Oh outside yeah he's
kind of like yo Sal yeah
and it like kicked the glass was like
with both of his feet and his tail was
like holding is all about everything is
ready it's jumping up except you ever
missed a v2 in the seat and not dig into
the lyrics on the new album so if you'll
humor me I'll start with you Brian this
is off the song beam featuring playboy
cardi laser beaming galaxy that [__]
flat b.o.b is that a flat earther
reference yes sir
it's [__] away actually
b.o.b follows me on Twitter and I follow
him and then there's one time I just
leave DM him such an [__] I do have a
picture of like a flat earth and I just
is this real shaping is never what this
is like a flat earth he's a killing zone
which once is called this is bun stirs
black label tattoos did it 16 out of 10
heat that's funny it's really funny is
60 doubt its head
[Music]
the long you had this before yes yes I
remember this
yes John shall we I'm holding on boys
it's all you do well you do but if you
are yours crazy cheers bro oh sweet
reprieve okay boys as we've touched on
today you've been more or less attached
at the hip bill last six months so what
we're gonna do is test your friendship
and we're doing it
newlywed game style what I'm gonna do is
ask you a series of questions if it'll
test how well you know each other let's
get the paper
we'll get the pen crap come Bobo I'm
sorry let's get you some more milk yeah
oh why was I [__] around like that
would think
what what what are you doing hey to
speak don't worry bye
[Music]
alright judge you don't go to hammer on
the mill you will end up muscular so
here's how this will work I'll ask a
question joji careful around your eyes
and you guys will each write down your
answer
no peeking at each other cuz this is how
it goes the first question is what is
Joe Gees favorite flavor of ice cream
Joe G will write down his favorite
flavor of ice cream Brian you'll write
down what you think Joe G's favorite
flavor of ice cream is and we'll see if
you match up okay advice that'd be nice
every [__] face just dip in my
grizzly you [__] with the dip hi Brian
what do you think is what do you think
Joe G's favorite flavor of ice cream is
show and tell but no oh [__] jouji
vanilla you guys are one for one one for
one
hi next what is Brian's favorite TV show
the most [__] up episode of all the
time all right jouji show-and-tell
Indonesia wait I knew that I'm sorry I
wasn't thinking straight [__] up yeah
you're right today's Idol this pretty
good show this Brian what do you think
is the one thing that Joe G likes best
about you can you feel your lips yeah
[Music]
ready all right show and tell Brian to
one good jawline nice ankles huh you got
nice ankles do i yeah
I think I did a little better last time
[Music]
since we've talked about the next
project it's a posse album so what I
want to do is show you some of the
biggest super groups in music industry
history and then I just want your
reactions you know the ones you like
maybe the ones you don't like as much if
you have any insight we'll just go from
there does that sound good
sounds great all right laptop please
odd future when you guys look at the
crew you've assembled and consider what
odd future is done do you see any
similarities in terms of like going into
like just and a lot of like just film
music like just any medium like I think
that's that's like there's more log
groups are doing now - it's just like
the new and improved format you know I
think and they they really start and
like kind of revolutionize that idea I
feel like so very very cool yeah two
more for you this is good music and you
guys are doing something different the
music industry with this crossover so
I'm wondering what do you think of this
summer particularly with this good music
remember what I love about Kanye is like
he's so down to just like make weird
[__] even if it's you know even if it
doesn't sound good or like even if
people may not like it it's hard to do
that as an artist you know sometimes you
want to make sure that you want to make
sure they think is like cool and
conceptual or whatever but sometimes you
know the kids need a song to have to
make out to you know you know that's
what you made midsummer madness and then
finally judge you what can you tell the
people about SMAP I never I never
learned their names because I'm racist
Nam Japanese okay
no I'm kidding I just never learned
their names but like I know this map is
SMAP in Japan would you say that they
inspired you in any way
yeah the fashion for sure yeah yeah the
carpet look I'm kidding no I'm so mean
no no shoutouts map is the [__] you
shoutouts map yeah all right boys
slam was just threw up a lot of the
table
this is the last dab in the ducts you
guys have both had the last stab this is
a new version with not only pepper axe
but a chocolate pepper axe as you know
it does not taste like chocolate
unfortunate I always echo chocolate but
it's tradition around here to put a
little extra on the last wing that's a
that's a thick sauce right there you
don't have to if you don't want to judge
I do I do
no way cuz they been anybody they just
had that that's just like now you know
I'm not gonna do it definitely not dj
khaled no dj khaled you can accounts at
rumor man you made all the weight here
that's [__] you oh [__] that I was
talking and I'm saying I didn't realize
this is hot sauce
there you go Brian huh what it rains it
pours
que sera sera monkey see monkey do what
does a when it rains it pours means
that's like I guess it's like it's
happening anyway so [__] it right yeah
[Music]
it's pretty weird so I'm like was it
chunks
let's do this alright boys you want
cheese on this [__] we win Cheers
it's going down what am i yelling timber
[Music]
Worf bet
you can't see but my eyes are going this
way I judge Ian rich Brian here we are
again at the end of the line it's a
place we've all been before and this
time we're gonna have one of our most
challenging wing 10 finales to date now
that your lips are burning stomachs our
journeys yeah I told you this looking to
catch up it's time to give you the floor
and see if you can tease us with a
little snippet from midsummer madness
jouji can you hit the hook with the
bajillion scovilles going through your
bloodstream Brian can you nail the verse
now that you've had 10 scorching hot
chicken wings down your throat so how do
we do this jouji hit me with that sweet
angelic melodic hook that I love so much
for mr. baddest we're gonna miss our
eyes
oh you [__] up I was wasted midsummer
madness I can't take it no more
No
[Applause]
[Music]
been a minute since I heard you want to
stay as friends I've learned from my
mistakes maybe you want to learn again I
really didn't know if I forgot my own
lyrics I don't give a [__] about another
man and look here listen no you miss
smiling when we [__] let's not even
think about it we ain't gotta talk a lot
even in the summer but we so impressive
and also killing the [__] wings not
once but now twice everybody with their
shades on now there's nothing left to do
but roll out the red carpet for you my
friends this camera this camera or this
camera let the people know what you have
going on in you listen head in the
clouds
idiot rats in summer album or idiot
rising album whatever the [__] you want
to call it he's gonna come out on July
July 20th having got the tour we got
will tour the and in the clouds Festival
LA but make sure when this album comes
out you gotta listen to it you gotta
support it because we work really hard
on this album we were literally in the
studio for like six weeks straight and
we were appearance a lot of late nights
together you know yeah yeah also while I
was doing that I was also slaving away
on my own [__] my own album which will
be coming out hopefully hopefully like
late August or something so am I
supposed to announce days okay yeah
always good to be back I leave tomorrow
morning
oh man I'm here all the [__] time we
got to get our house we got to get her
like oh yes yes
that's going to be fun
Aloha spice Lords if you're wondering
why I'm sitting on this beautiful beach
it's because I'm celebrating Lowe's
calientes the sauce of summer in the
newest addition to the hot ones hot
sauce family this is Beach vibes in a
bottle sweet smoky spicy and I might be
biased but I think it's the best hot
sauce we've ever made and here's the
exciting news if you want to pick up a
bottle it's available now you know the
drill heat nice calm heat nice calm for
your bottle of lows calientes lows
calientes muy delicioso
[Music]